how you doing your freedom loving freaks
i'm dave rubin it's january 21st 2022
this is the reuben report direct message
yes from florida
i'm still i'm i'm still overjoyed i'm
still just bubbling with effervescence
and happiness and floridian
wonderfulness
that's going to be my new tagline a man
full of floridian wonderfulness it's all
good we got a q a for you today we got
dozens and dozens of questions at
reubenreport.locals.com and once again i
just want to thank you guys for bearing
with us this week as we built out the
temporary studio the schedule has been a
little crazy things have been a little
upside down working on some technical
stuff a few of you mentioned that
yesterday we had some audio issues we've
worked them out i think you're going to
be very happy with the audio crispness
today
and it's a special day because clyde is
in studio i'll see if maybe we can get
him on my lap a little bit later but the
gardeners are here they've got a lot of
cleaning to do at this new place it's
very overgrown here in florida a lot of
growth a lot of water a lot of rain
humidity trees etc
and they're outside and i didn't want
him barking like crazy although i have
to say that we've soundproofed this
thing pretty freaking well
anyway uh before we get to the q a i've
got a great story about nancy pelosi she
said something completely completely
insane i'll get to that in just a moment
but i want to talk to you find people
about bonner private wine did you know
what's in the bottle of wine that's
sitting on the kitchen counter of your
house do you know what's in there i bet
you don't know what's in there
traditional media won't tell you this
try oak flavoring mega purple dye and
tons of sugar and that's not counting
all the chemicals left over from
vineyards that look more like oil
refineries than great chateaus of old
but better wines do exist and they don't
cost an arm and a leg to get either take
it from america's top wine explorer
recently he came across a wine unlike
anything he's ever tasted problem is
this delicious red wine can only be
found in a single isolated corridor
known as the world's most remote wine
valley
heck he nearly died twice trying to find
these vineyards that's commitment the
wine is that special want to give them a
try jump over to bonner private wines
and my audience can get these rare wines
at half the retail price no need for a
promo code plus you'll get fifty percent
off shipping this wine is truly
something special but supplies are
limited visit bonner
privatewines.com
dave to claim your wine that's bonner
privatewines.com
dave and now back to me okay so before
we get to the q a nancy pelosi do you
know this woman she lives up there
somewhere in the northern cali san
francisco area she is a crazy woman who
has been in politics
for roughly 800 years her eyebrows are
very high sometimes it seems her
dentures are falling out she's very
confused she used to be somewhat maybe
20 years ago sort of sane but the crazy
radicals in her party have just whacked
her over the head and now she's just
bananas she loves ice cream she loves
locking people down she's looking to buy
a house in florida i don't like this
woman very much
she said something yesterday
that i think literally
and i mean this literally not
figuratively i think literally might be
the most insane thing ever said by an
american politician in modern times it
is so
authentically bananas
that you have to hear it yourself
uh madam speaker i understand that last
thursday you asked the committee on
house administration to take a closer
look at stockx violations by members of
congress um which you know may include
different penalties for these violations
as well i wanted to again talk about
just why you did that why i think that's
important and what you say to the
members of your caucus which range from
frontline members to some of the most
progressive members who want to go
further and ask them well i don't know
that i mean that's your version here's
the thing
i say to my members
on a regular basis when we gather in
caucus and as you know sometimes it's
hybrid these days but anytime we have
gathered in caucus when we're actually
virtually or hybrid i've said to them
under this roof figuratively or actually
is the greatest collection
of intellect
integrity
and imagination for doing the right
thing for the american people i have
great
confidence in the contemporary of my
members
they
are remarkable
we're back are we back okay
sorry in the middle of something else
while we're playing the clip
uh did you catch what she said there did
you catch that
i want to quote her in case you didn't
fully catch it she said that house
democrats represent quote
the greatest collection of intellect
integrity
and imagination anywhere
before i comment on that directly
it made me think of something
take a look
what you just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things i have ever heard
at no point in your rambling incoherent
response
were you even close to anything
that could be considered a rational
thought
everyone in this room is now dumber for
having listened to it
god have mercy on your soul
ah the great billy madison adam sandler
at his peak that thing that she said was
completely insane the greatest
collection of intellect
intellect yes ilhan omar aoc rashida
talib adam schiff
nancy pelosi ted liu intellect
integrity
yes aoc rashida talib ilhan omar adam
schiff ted lou nancy pelosi integrity
and imagination
you got the point these are the worst
sort of authoritarian controlling
unimaginative that's the key here
let's put aside intellect for a second i
don't think these people are
particularly bright like do you have
these people created great businesses
have they created great industries have
they innovated products like no they've
become
bureaucratic middle men who just control
your life so
intellect i don't know like they became
people who got power so i suppose if you
think that has something to do with
intellect we could go with that
integrity i mean these people are all
chronic
liars and deceivers and and in many ways
evil people which i don't like using
that term but at some point you just got
to call it what it is people that lock
down their own people in you know
anti-science measures and believe in all
these mandates and all of this stuff
while they vacation like you guys know
the drill on all of this stuff so it's
like integrity these people are liars
ted lewis he's called me racist a couple
times on twitter like
they have no integrity they have nothing
close to integrity and imagination is
just like the fun one here like what
imagination do these people have their
answers are all government their answers
are give me more money
give me more power you know what's
imagination you know what uses
imagination the human mind when you
figure out how to do new stuff when you
figure out how to live the way you want
to live when you figure out how to work
with other people in fun ways to create
new exciting things and products
like that's cool like that's cool that's
using the imagination you think these
people have any imagination lady
that is just
completely insane can we play that billy
madison clip one more time it's it's one
of my favorites nancy pelosi says that
the house democrats have intellect
integrity and imagination
what you just said
is one of the most insanely idiotic
things i have ever heard
at no point
in your rambling incoherent response
were you even close to anything that
could be considered a rational thought
everyone in this room
is now dumber for having listened to it
god have mercy on your soul i mean
that's just good stuff look sandler
ain't what he used to be okay i'm not
gonna sit here and pretend he has the
netflix movie since he signed that 87
million or whatever it was deal with
netflix the movies have all sucked
basically but like you give me some
billy madison and some of the early days
stuff like there's there's some good
stuff there the wedding singer there's
some good stuff all right guys before we
get to the q a real quick i want to talk
to you about three day blinds is all of
the news on rising inflation and crime
rates making you want to shut out the
world well you're not alone and i have a
solution for you it's called three-day
blinds they are the leading manufacturer
and retailer of custom window treatments
in the united states and right now they
are running a buy one get one fifty
percent off deal with three day blinds
they bring the showroom to you their
local professionally trained designed
consultants provide expert advice in the
comfort of your home just set up an
appointment and you'll get a free quote
the same day their expert team handles
all the heavy lifting they design
measure and install so you can sit back
and relax no matter your unique need
from motorization and home automation to
room darkening and child safety
three-day blinds has a window treatment
for you choose from thousands of options
that fit any budget or style and with
actual samples that means no guessing on
what your blinds will look like by the
way we use three day blinds they weren't
even a sponsor we used three day blinds
for our blinds in the los angeles reuben
report studio and i think we can make
some good use of them here a clever
feature i love is that you can set the
time of your shades to open or close at
the preset times the day that's what we
used to do back at the old studio three
day blinds have been in business for
over 40 years and have thousands of five
star reviews so they are a brand you can
trust right now you can get three day
blinds
right now at three day blinds you can
buy one get one for 50 off on custom
blinds shades and drapery for a free no
charge no obligation consultation just
head on over to 3dayblinds.com
ruben and use my code ruben
that's right buy one get one for 50 off
when you head over to 3dayblinds.com
ruben and use my promo code ruben one
last time that's the number three day
day blinds.com ruben
and now back to me all right guys let's
dive into the q a first up is curtis was
it difficult to find a house to set up a
studio in where the hoa the homeowners
association allowed for a home business
so actually it did not come up uh where
i live is not uh
in hoa so there is no
like home association so i didn't have
to get approved by a board or anything
like that like it was actually all good
buying a house in florida especially in
south florida miami area was actually
extremely difficult because the market
is so hot and i mentioned the other day
it's like there are all sorts of
competing offers and you're competing
against people with cash and i didn't
have that kind of cash and you're
competing with you know just all of the
people that are fleeing all of these
other states and and also people are
sort of desperate and i would include
myself in that like i felt very
desperate when we came here a couple
times to visit uh you may remember over
a few months of the of the fall like i
was disappearing for like little
three-day trips and i was kind of
winking at you guys like i got something
coming uh and i would come the first
time david and i came then i came once
alone once then i brought my team a
couple times because i wanted to make
sure everybody wanted to move but all of
the houses when you go to open houses or
you go with agents it's like there's a
desperation
on the part of the people that are
buying and so the sellers know that so
it's a great place if you're in florida
right now and you've been sitting on a
property you're not living in it's like
this is a great place this is a great
time to sell
so fortunately we don't have an hoa here
so i was able to do whatever i wanted
with the studio we can basically build
whatever we want in the house florida
also has way way better
regulations
in general and when i say better i mean
less right so california's got a ton of
regulations we had crazy things i mean
there were really nutty things when i
had my old studio in the garage
so the previous studio before the last
one the last one was in my office but
you guys remember the old one where we
did most of the in-person stuff that was
in my garage we only had one car we had
a two-car driveway
and a two-car garage we only had one car
plenty of street parking there was a
regulation in los angeles that if you
turned your garage into anything other
than an area for cars even if you had
one car and a two-car driveway even if
you had no cars that you had to build an
outdoor carport
now first off they have no right to tell
you what you should do with your own
property in my estimation but only that
the weather in southern california in
los angeles it's basically 78 to 82 and
sunny every day
what are they protecting under that
carport
it's just completely bananas but this is
what they do they get bureaucrats
involved and then you're not going to
believe it but most likely the guy who
builds the carport probably is the
cousin of the guy who pushed for the
ordinance in the first place it's just
like an endless cycle of complete
nonsense so here there's way less red
tape on all of that stuff there's not
nothing but there's way less red tape we
were able to build actually very quickly
as i mentioned the only
real issue is that the supply chain
stuff is slow which has very little if
not nothing to do with florida that has
way more to do with the federal
government right now and florida is
actually doing a pretty good job
desantis is opening up ports helping
ships get in here but even here because
not everything is manufactured here and
you got to get things across the country
and everything else even here it's been
hard to get things so i mentioned you
know ikea didn't have a lot of stuff
even target
had a lot of bare shelves like we're
slogging through the best we can but we
were able to put this together and pull
it together and we're going to work on
the the permanent studio as quickly as
possible so if you're just tuning in no
i'm not back in los angeles in the old
studio and no that's not even a real
background behind me it's a big ass tv
but we will be building the proper
studio out soon enough burn says what is
clyde thinking about the totally empty
house oh we're making a move on me
uh what is clyde thinking about the
totally empty house dogs have fine ears
the acoustics in the empty mansion must
feel strange to him so first off clyde
is in studio right now we got a couple
clip pictures of clyde that i snapped
right before he is about a foot away
from me right here he's in studio
because the gardeners are coming i
didn't want him barking and freaking
everybody out i want to introduce him to
the gardeners show them that they are
not enemies coming to assault or
otherwise attack us but i couldn't do
that since i'm in here so clyde is
joining us in the show uh in studio
today i'll see if i can get him out on
camera in a bit clyde you wanna you
wanna get on camera
oh he's he's licking the special area so
we'll we'll see what we can do about
that later um but yeah we pretty much
have nothing in the house so show the
picture of just clyde just empty yeah we
don't have anything here because our
stuff from la hasn't arrived yet it's
going to take about two weeks you guys
know all the nonsense with the trucks
they're coming
from california but then they have
nothing to bring back from florida there
aren't enough truck drivers so
everything is massively delayed so we
got one couch i think we have one other
picture there no we don't have another
picture we uh we bought one couch from
the guy who lived here before just
because i was like i need a place to sit
for two weeks so we got a couch and i
got a wayfarer carpet
and i bought a couple uh plates at ikea
and i made a chicken and broccoli last
night very impromptu
and we're doing the best we can but yeah
it's cavernous and it's loud and there
you know there aren't enough carpets and
rugs and all that kind of stuff so when
he barks it's a little echoey and
painful but it's all good it's all good
and we do have one full wall i i posted
a picture on this uh of this in the
locals community we have one full wall
that is alligator skin which is pretty
cool so it's true we are in florida in
case you weren't paying attention
danielle says hey dave i heard you talk
about your roots doing stand-up comedy
any chance you could post some of your
old skits on locals i would love to see
that side of you we have a whole bunch
of old stuff that i'm trying to figure
out what we want to do like if i want to
do like a real hour-long special and
then we would intersperse some of that
stuff or how we would want to release it
you know when i was on tour with jordan
if we had an off night i would sell out
basically whatever club we were in
whatever city we were in we had a great
we sold out literally every single show
that we did i would do about an hour a
stand-up and it's mostly messing with
the crowd and talking about the news and
just having fun it's this but with you
know 500 people in the room um and i
love doing that i don't love the idea of
like writing an hour's worth of jokes
and what's the deal with lampshades like
all right you know i lived that life it
was a different life is what it is um
but i do want to get back out on the
road and i especially want to spend some
time just like meeting more people and
going to more cities here in florida
particularly uh you know my next book's
coming out in april and i will be
touring i have a call with my guys
actually later today to discuss how
we're going to do that because i'm not
going to cities and venues where they're
going to have mass mandates or they're
going to have vaccine passports or any
of that nonsense so that's going to you
know tighten the tour but maybe i can do
more shows in cities that will allow it
it's going to cost us a bunch of money i
just don't care i think you have to
stand up and do what's right sometimes
if not all the time and that's the way
we're going to do it and when i do those
live shows it's not stand up per se but
it's like a version of this
a little bit about the book maybe i'll
bring on some special guests all that
good stuff cheryl says with starbucks
surprising move to lift vaccine mandates
for its employees do you anticipate any
others following suit i'm thinking of
major corporations
like banks and airlines so if you
haven't heard about this it just broke
in the last day or so
since the osha mandate got turned around
starbucks is basically saying they're
not going to force their employees to
wear masks now it's a little unclear to
me exactly how starbucks works they're
not franchise they're all owned by the
corporation starbucks if i understand
this correctly so they get their
messaging from the corporation so in
other words if it was a franchise like
let's say subway is a franchise so
you're basically licensing you as the as
the franchisee you are licensing subway
their branding their logo all the stuff
and then you run the store as you want
and then you got to deal with whatever's
going on with the laws in your city
everything else starbucks as a national
chain it sounds like they are not going
to force their employees to wear man
masks now the problem
is that they've gone so in on the
wokeness at starbucks they've gone so in
on
masks and vaccines and mandates that i
suspect that a huge percentage of their
employees are brainwashed enough to
think that they have to wear these
things forever and we'll keep them on i
would guess it would be my guess that if
they were to i don't know how many do
can we find out how many total employees
starbucks has in the united states i
mean they obviously have thousands and
thousands of employees i'm going to
guess that in terms of the people
working at the stores it's going to end
up being something like 80 percent
of the employees will continue to wear
masks maybe not in certain places like
here in florida some places in texas etc
but i think people have been so
conditioned to it and that's the problem
two weeks to flatten the curve we're now
two years later what have we done to
people what have we made people think
what have we
done to make people afraid of other
human beings and afraid to interact with
each other and everything else so i
think a lot of people are going to
continue to do it now look if it's their
choice it's their choice
right so i'm not saying you should force
them not to wear it it's their choice so
be it but it's just it's not good for
the for the human condition overall in
2020 starbucks had
350 000
employees in the united states i mean
that's pretty crazy and if you don't
believe me that they've gone in all on
the woke stuff and the nonsense and
everything else you may remember a story
i think we covered it about a year ago
where they said that they were going to
allow
uh you know homeless people to come and
use the bathrooms and their stores and
everything else so what happened was
they had all these homeless people
especially new york city taking over
stores and then they just removed all
the chairs and the tables because they
didn't want people basically building
bunkers there so it's like the road to
hell is paved with good intentions
people
but
to your broader point i hope this
spreads i hope that the idea that
starbucks is going to leave it to the
people hopefully or or i suppose maybe
to the local managers but that's not
good too because if you got a crazy
paranoid manager then all your employees
who want to take the take the masks off
won't be able to i don't know how that
fully works logistically within the
company but to the broader point yeah
banks got to start doing it hotels that
is one thing for sure hotels and
restaurants when we were in boca last
week we stayed at i think it was a
marriott for a week
and the amount of all of the employees
behind the desk the bellhops janitors
etc all wearing masks all wearing masks
and i even said to a girl
who was cleaning up in the gym i said
hey we were the only two people in there
said hey you don't have to wear the mask
for me and she kind of took it down a
little bit beneath her nose
but like at some point that that doesn't
hold first off these people are not our
slaves we don't own these people these
are hard jobs in service industry and
they should be treated equally if not
better than the rest of us and it also
will create class warfare it shouldn't
just be the people who serve people at
restaurants and waiters and who cook and
who you know bring luggage upstairs that
they'll have to wear masks forever but
you people with a couple bucks in your
pocket you won't have to what a recipe
for class warfare disaster which perhaps
is exactly what the democrats want at
this point uh kathy says is there any
way to get covidius back are they lost
are they a lost cause i met someone
yesterday who thought if you get coveted
you die
this is the gajillion dollar question
right like this is this is absolutely a
tough one like what do you do this is so
consistent not only with covert but all
of the people who have been brainwashed
by all of this stuff the people who
thought that donald trump was defending
white supremacists the people who
thought that the covington kids were
racist brett kavanaugh was a serial
rapist
written house was an axe murderer all of
the things that they have lied to us
about
a certain percentage of people are
brainwashed mass formation psychosis
while they tell us that we are the crazy
paranoid ones and what do you do for the
people who still think that masks don't
that masks work
even while now the cdc is backtracking
on some of that stuff the people who now
two years later are like okay maybe mass
don't work so i'll put on an n95 mask
and i'll walk around like darth vader
like what do you do about that
i don't know how we wake these people up
it's it's very difficult i should
probably do a show let's book somebody
about deprogramming people from cults i
think that actually would be a great
idea
because it's a pretty close parallel
where you've accepted a worldview that
is not true and even at the steps where
you see that it's not true you always
find a reason that it is true right so
it's like when they told you okay if you
get vaccinated you will not get or
transmit kovid joe biden anthony fauci
walensky at the cdc etc they all said
this now they're literally saying after
the fourth booster shot it may not stop
omicron and probably will not and by the
way you don't have to listen to them for
that stuff it's like what has happened
to you in your own life
in the last month
i am not vaccinated i got kovid my
brother is vaccinated he got coveted
we're both okay he's a little younger
than me everybody's all right that's not
to say everyone is okay all the time
but we have to like think about these
things honestly so when it hits you in
your own life and you go wait a minute
they told me if i got vaccinated that
i'd be okay and i wouldn't transmit it
and i wouldn't get it and all of that
stuff and now it's oh you just won't get
that sick but then you see people who
aren't
vaxxed and they don't get that sick it's
like
a little logic a little reason just do
the best you can to to keep reaching out
to these people i'm trying and it ain't
easy it ain't easy and i will not sit
here and pretend that it is
jacob asks do you think that a
republican can win the governorship in
massachusetts this year with charlie
baker not running again and a mass
exodus of republicans away from blue
states so i'll be totally honest with
you i actually don't know a tremendous
amount about internal massachusetts
politics and maybe we can get somebody
on to talk about that i actually would
love to do a show
maybe i'll get a political
uh a political expert i don't know what
the right word is but somebody who
really tracks the migration stuff and
really tracks sort of internal state
politics you know obviously i'm pretty
well versed in what's going on in
florida now i'm pretty well versed in
that west coast place i used to live in
um but i don't know a tremendous amount
about massachusetts however i do know
that an awful lot of people i've met a
whole bunch of i mean people leave in
boston people leaving some of those
cities in massachusetts and they're
coming to the free state um so you know
one of the problems at some level i
suppose is as
the migration patterns that we talked
about on the show yesterday as they
continue to strengthen right and as we
continue to see you know conservative
minded but it's not even really that
it's just like people who just want to
live their life as we continue to see
them
move towards red states right well then
what happens is you don't have any
counterbalance in the blue states so if
the blue states have been like you know
sort of
leaning right and they're kind of going
off the ledge right they're gonna go and
kind of going
and then there's nothing holding them
back anymore because the good people who
are fighting against the tyranny against
the authoritarianism if they're not
there well then the blue states are just
going to get worse and then i guess
you'll have more of a fleeing so in some
ways the entropy around all of this is
that the states are just going to go in
their separate directions and as you
know that's what federalism was all
about and i think it actually could be
okay
elizabeth says what's the timing for
david's cookbook release my husband is
obsessed with the skillet chicken parm
recipe and keeps asking me if david has
any other good ones he should try well
first off he should go to
davidscookbook.com where david's got a
ton of recipes his uh
uh what is it not boneless chicken wings
the the unfried chicken wings have been
blowing up absolutely blowing up you're
talking about the uh
the skillet the pan it's basically a
cast iron chicken parm which a lot of
people said oh you don't put red sauce
into chicken
in a cast iron you can do it people and
it works and it's delicious
candace owens
youtube internet personality candace
owens said it was the best chicken parm
she's ever had
so you can go to davidscookbook.com to
find out more of his recipes you can
also go to instagram.com
david's cookbook he's working on the
cookbook obviously the last two months
with a move and everything else have
delayed some things and now we just have
a lot to do here
i would hope by the end of the year
perhaps but now i just said it out loud
so i've either put undue pressure or
i've ruined the entire thing we shall
find out but i'm looking forward to
eating some home-cooked meals again you
know when you when you move
it ends up one way or another and
because we don't have anything here it's
a lot of takeout a lot of chinese a lot
of thai a lot of oils a lot of pasta a
lot of pizza
we're having a healthy lunch today right
guys no more i can't i can't do the uh i
can't do the pizza anymore sorry i'm
starting to lose it uh john says
polls suggest that hispanics and to some
extent black americans are dissatisfied
with biden what can should the
republican party be doing to make it
clear to these americans with similar
values who are wholeheartedly or that
they are wholeheartedly welcome
in the tent well you know there's some
interesting things that'll happen by
default uh i'm gonna roughly get these
numbers right but in dc right now where
they have the indoor vax mandate
there's something like 50
of black adults in dc are not
uh vaccinated or do not have the
vaccination card and the black community
has their own reasons as to why they
might be leery of government injected
stuff okay so that means right now
roughly half of the black people in dc
technically cannot go into restaurants
and they can technically not go into
restaurants because of the democratic
mayor i think her name is muriel bowser
if i'm not mistaken
that is because of a democrat a democrat
is saying black people you can't come
into these restaurants a democrat in new
york city bill de blasio who just walked
out absolutely destroyed new york city
obviously a lot of latino and black
people new york city in the boroughs
same thing in dc some same thing in
these big cities eric adams who happens
to be black who is the new mayor of new
york there was like a three-day window
where people thought he was saying and
it's very clear he's gonna go in with
the woke nonsense and the anti-police
stuff and the rest of it so
if you live in these cities i mean it's
just the proof is in the pudding right
like you just have to look around is
crime up or down oh it's up and who's in
charge oh it's the democrats
are things better or worse at schools oh
they're worse and who's in charge it's
the democrats who run the teachers union
it's the democrats like i hate to sound
so partisan with all of this stuff and i
don't think 10 years ago the the
partisan lunacy was like this yes of
course there was liberals versus
conservatives democrats first
republicans blah blah blah
but like now it's just freaking obvious
i cannot imagine
someone walking around going it sure is
great here in new york
it sure is great here in los angeles and
san francisco and portland these are all
democrat-run places
do you think those things maybe have
something to do with each other you
think there's a little touch point there
so i think the best thing that
republicans can do is actually not play
the identity politics game and i think
they're getting pretty good at it right
now and i think in many ways you got to
give trump credit for this trump did not
care about the cultural issues in that
regard so what i mean by that is you
remember the moment there was a great
moment
i think it was during the campaign trial
maybe it was when trump was president
the trans thing can we find out when
they said to trump well what do you
think about trans bathrooms i think
maybe it was before he was president
because that was big during the obama
the obama time and trump said hey i
build hotels i build buildings if you're
telling me i only have to build one
bathroom then everybody can go to it
that's just great like that is the right
answer
that is the right answer live as you
want to live you know and trump lived as
a builder i don't really care where you
pay is it is it that big of a deal but
they want to make it the most important
thing so they can bludgeon us with all
of this stuff stuff they wanted to make
it seem like trump was a racist and it
was like black unemployment was at an
all-time low under trump and you'll
never forget remember that moment
at the state of the union when the
congressional black caucus when trump's
talking about low all-time black
unemployment and they sat there like
this
and you'd think that the congressional
black caucus
might be for low black unemployment so i
think there's going to be massive shifts
you know there's a big thing in texas
right now also where latino
immigrants legal immigrants they don't
want illegal immigrants coming they
don't want or they want them to come
legally they don't want just people
flooding into their borders so there's a
new thing now where the the cities some
of the border cities that have
republican mayors they're more
right-wing than their counterparts so
all the things are flipping and i would
hope that as america continues over the
next let's say two decades
that the people that will scream about
race and and identity
they're all going to be the lefties and
the rest of us will just move on and
basically we did it i mean that's the
thing we really did do it in america and
if you think about the woke project in
the last two let's say five years as
this thing really exploded in the last
two years because of kovid it's like
who's really screaming about race in
america who is racist in america today
like do you honestly think donald trump
is racist donald trump wants laws racist
laws against black people or hispanics
do you think ron desantis is racist can
you give me a republican that you're
like boy that person really does want
laws that are going to stop those people
from doing what they want because of the
color of skin or is all of the racist
stuff coming out of the wok left who
want quotas who want to make sure that
some people can go to schools and some
people can't who want to punish people
when it comes to the workplace and
decide who gets promotions based on
gender and skin color and all of that
nonsense
i think you know the answer you're smart
and that's why you watch the reuben
report all right next uh
jancy says i was wondering since anthony
fauci is the science has anyone asked
him how many genders there are that's a
good question and a fine follow-up to my
previous point right exactly exactly
there are two genders male and female
you can be born female and identify as a
male you are still
biologically female
i don't think anthony fauci would be
willing to say that i really don't it
would be a great question for somebody
to ask him
richard says as a conservative
libertarian what do you think about the
republic what do you think republican
governors should do with regards to
legalizing weed is being in favor of
weed legalization possibly an advantage
for conservatives this is a great
question it's it's very complex
my feelings about generally about
legalizing weed i am for legalizing
marijuana i'm not gonna sit here and
pretend that i haven't smoked marijuana
okay i have i got the glancoma i can't
you know it helps it takes the pressure
off the retina um people can smoke weed
if you want to smoke weed i don't think
kids should be smoking weed
you know the counter to that that has
become an uncomfortable truth to me is
that in the places where wheat has
become legal
it does seem that there's now a
correlation with the general sort of
collapse of society like where when l.a
legalized it it's like l.a started
getting work new york city like smells
like weed it used to smell like homeless
people now they got homeless people plus
weed the weed kind of masks the homeless
people sometimes in the summer it's the
reverse um
[Music]
that being said i don't think because of
some sort of unintended consequences you
should restrict people's freedom so if
you believe that people should be
allowed to drink alcohol which alcohol
we know is not good for you it's just
not like everything in moderation is
okay fine um but way more people die of
cirrhosis of the liver way more people
die of drunk driving and all sorts of
stuff no one has ever smoked weed and
robbed a bank or committed a violent
assault or anything like that people
usually smoke weed to relax or get silly
or stupid or take a walk in the park or
whatever you do the point is if you
believe in choice if the libertarian
part of you believes in choice then i
get then that i to me has to override
the conservative sort of principle of we
have to have these very strict
guidelines on a society to tell people
what to do to me that's more of like a
personal familial thing so that you'd
want society to have things that are
legal within limits right i'm not for
legalizing heroin i've debated this with
michael malus like i wouldn't want a
meth lab next door to me so society does
exist for some reason and you have to
have some guardrails i fully believe
that which is why i usually don't
describe myself as a libertarian it was
why i was always saying i'm a classical
liberal because we believe in some of
those guardrails
as opposed to libertarians that that
generally don't they don't want to put
everything on the individual but we do
live in a society of people however i'm
not saying sitting here saying what don
lemon said yesterday that we covered
about the greater good of society
because that is a very dangerous place
to go to
all that being said uh i think you have
to have some of these guardrails and you
have to balance sort of what publicly
okay we're not going to arrest people
for doing something with their own body
and then the family part of it or the
culture part of it or the religious part
of it or wherever you get your ethics
and your morals that should deal with
say the
whether you're going to do it or not
right so there's a difference between
the legal side and what you personally
would partake in
okay got to move quick here colt says do
you plan to have meetups in north
florida one of these days yes absolutely
we'll make it happen as i said we're
figuring out the book tour and i
definitely will get i haven't spent a
ton of time in northern florida i know
i've heard that pensacola area is great
i was up in tallahassee tallahassee with
desantis a couple weeks ago but i
haven't spent much time there it's
usually
usually in south florida actually where
i have some family southwest florida now
i'm in southeast part but yeah i want to
bounce all over the place uh ross my
leftist sister excommunicated me for
opposing vax mandates and upon
discovering that i'm conservative my
parents share my values but won't
address the hypocrisy of my sisters only
hating me how do i bring my family back
together look i don't know i don't know
everyone has these problems i have my
own
issues in the family every everybody
does when politics becomes religion and
people think that if you don't make the
same choices they make or listen to the
same news that they listen to or all of
that stuff it is deeply deeply dangerous
and i don't have a perfect answer for it
i think the best thing you can do is try
to be a little bit better try to be a
little bit more open and honest and
understanding but it ain't easy i know
it ain't easy especially as people are
saying you killed grandma
and you know the power you're racist and
all of that stuff it is not easy but i
think if you can just be a little bit
better over time it sort of works itself
out
adam have you and david got bbq set up
what's cooking this weekend in the
florida sun we don't have the bbq set up
and there's no outdoor cooking situation
here which i'm going to try to build out
something at some point
but the smoker is on the way it's on the
truck and i can't wait to just get back
in and smoke some brisket and maybe
we'll smoke some gator is that a thing
smoked gator that seems like something
uh and uh all right two more real quick
mark what is one thing we're not
collectively talking about that we could
benefit
from discussing
that's a good one
that we're not collectively talking
about well i don't know if you mean we
meaning the people that watch this show
you guys and the things that i talk
about here you mean sort of broader
society but i would say actually the
biggest thing that we should be focusing
on more is going to be this push for us
all to live in a digital world we've
talked about it a bit here but this real
push for meta and virtual reality
and you know it's partly why i think
they want the real world to collapse and
make it so miserable out there so you
think you're going to catch a disease if
you go outside and they wanted to sort
of destroy your jobs and universal basic
income because they would love to have
us just strapped to a machine where you
know we've got something on our face and
we can decide what we're buying and we
can pretend we're all things that we're
not i mean it's really what the matrix
was about you know like we become the
batteries for the machine and by they i
mean i don't know who i mean exactly but
it's sort of like the elites who will be
on boats and they will be outside and
they will not be teaching their kids all
these bad ideas but the rest of us will
be the batteries for the fantastic real
world that they will live in and we got
to fight that we really got to fight
that and finally
jacob says what do you think they pump
into joe biden to keep him animated
i don't know
but
as that woman said in when harry met
sally i'll have what she's having like
whatever they pump him with so that he
occasionally has a lucid moment which is
fairly uh infrequent at this point it's
like they they are able to get him in
order sometimes but we've all seen this
there are some talks that he gives where
he's like a little more functional he
stands up a little straighter his face
looks a little brighter and then there's
somewhere he's really kind of talking
like this and he's very tired and he's
looking around and he's confused and
then the stumbling and the mumbling and
all of those things
so again i am not saying that
to belittle anyone with any of those
problems and we should all be concerned
about mental health and we should all do
what we can for our own cognitive
abilities and to strengthen our brain
and all of that i do take some sort of
memory pill it's something you know it's
a little mushroom pill or something i
don't know david gives me something in
the morning have it with the coffee you
know here i am um but whatever they're
juicing them with man it's like you
gotta you gotta mass produce that
because if regular people could have
whatever it is they are pumping and full
of in the morning think about productive
we could all be i guess it's adderall i
don't know anyway uh all right this was
week one of our shows live from the
house here in florida we will be
building out the big studio we got a lot
of good things coming
it was a great week it was good to be
back in here with you guys i thank you
for watching have a great weekend
everybody and if you want to play along
and chat with me over the weekend and
all that good stuff join us at
reubenreport.locals.com
and i'll see you on monday